uh so yeah my name is anand ranganathan
and today i'll be talking about
a new way for people to explore data
that we call natural language and
conversational in analysis on interfaces
so the core focus is to make it easy for
non-technical business users even the
general public to ask questions on
databases without having to know no sql
or python or other bi tools
so we want to completely democratize
data make it easy anybody knows english
should know how to get to data that's
our that's our goal
so i'll talk to in today's talk i'll
talk about our vision for this new
paradigm of exploring data and how how
we've designed our product around this
so today how do people consume data it's
mostly through charts and dashboards and
there's been a couple of talks before on
on possible depth of dashboards uh which
i won't go to detail
but this is the way most people look at
data there's you know there's teams of
an enterprise that produce charts and
dashboards and you see charts and
dashboards every day so even in for
instance with covet there's like a
massive explosion of charts being
produced about
all aspects of kovid
but dashboards are limited so there are
several disadvantages of of dashboards
so firstly you know the dashboard is
offers a snapshot of a piece of data in
time you can't you often can't drill
down in in different ways unless those
drill downs has been explicitly
configured and even then it's you know
there's very limited in what you can do
you often don't know how the data for
the dashboard was produced so
you don't know what the source data was
what what transformations might have
happened in the dashboard creator or
created to produce the final charts
uh you also can't ask a different
question so each chart answers one
question but if you want to ask the
questions in a different way explore
some different aspects of the data the
dashboard chart doesn't have to do that
and one of the biggest issues i think
with dashboards is that i almost think
of
and this is this has been talked about
in many other
[Music]
sessions is that
data analysis is still an artisanal kind
of endeavor so the each dashboard
creator or each you know report creator
is an artist that's looking at the raw
data and figuring out what's most
interesting and presenting it in some
possibly biased manner right so it's
easy to cherry picks to actually pick
some personal data to to create the
right story and hence charts and
dashboards can often be quite misleading
so to realize all these problems with
with dashboards and you know
we think there has to be a better way
right
and that's where our our approach of
conversational and natural language
interfaces to data comes in
so what is conversational analytics or
is our definition of it and even
gartner's definition of it now
the ability to allow users to ask
questions of data in either text or
voice and get back a natural language
and or visual analysis of the results
in a manner that's relevant to the user
and to have all this happen in a
conversational setting where it's not
just one query but you can keep asking
more queries in a conversational manner
so for this talk i'm going to focus on
structured data specifically uh so
asking questions on structured data
which is typically presented in some
relation format either in sql or sql
like databases in excel sheets and other
tabular formats
so this is a product i won't spend too
much time on the marketing of sales but
this is one standard product itself uh
so we have product a bot called cubo uh
hopefully at some point it'll be as
popular as alexa and siri in other such
sports but we have bought called cubo
which allows people to have natural
language conversations with their data
especially within collaboration
platforms so cubo acts as an ai power
data analyst so at some point in the
future like you know all jobs even data
analysis will probably be replaced by ai
maybe you're taking the first steps over
there so but kubo allows people to have
natural language conversations with
their data within collaboration
platforms and the collaboration
platforms i mean platforms like
microsoft teams slack zoom and others
so
in cuba you can ask questions you can
ask descriptive questions like what
happened last month
and how many policies expiring in a
given month why would the fewer customer
acquisitions you can ask diagnostic
questions as well
like why do sales drop you can also ask
predictor questions i'll show you some
examples of all those kinds of questions
behind the scenes the main part of cubo
is the ability to convert natural
language to sql
and or python based machine learning
models
uh apply or send those queries to a
backend database get back the answers if
necessary apply more anal analytical
processing on those on the results and
present the results back to end users
so users can work in a different
enterprise databases users can converse
with kuber to ask questions and then
they can collaborate with one another
because it's part of teams and soon
slack as well so as to explore data
jointly
so the way this is set up is that
kubo sits in between one or more users
and
variety of data sets so today we support
two main interfaces a
a web browser interface as well as a
microsoft teams interface and we support
over 20 different kinds of backend
database connectors all the popular
databases
snowflake redshift you know
even excel sheets as well as
applications like salesforce google
analytics errors
so
depending on the question users ask cuba
can connect to one or more of these
enterprise databases either internal
sometimes external as well
gets get back the answers and shows the
answers to the end users
so i spent a majority of talk going
through kind of a
a demo of the of the platform but
focusing on some of the key challenges
and some of our initial approaches to to
tackle this issue
so for the purpose of the demo i'm going
to actually focus on a data set that i i
set up
last week on 311 data from from austin
anybody from austin here
okay so might be relevant so some of
these some of these might be relevant to
you so three one one data
uh
so three on one data as you know is uh
so whenever anybody any citizen of the
city of austin or any to any of or
initiative really has any kind of
complaint like there's potholes there's
a loose dog and loose dogs pretty
popular in austin
uh they would raise a 311 request so
austin has been doing a good job of
collecting his data and making it public
so there is a site in the austin
tech
data or austin in texas.gov where this
data is being updated almost on a daily
basis so i i think it was snapshot of
this data last week and uh put it in
snowflakes so there are 1.2 million rows
in this data there's a variety of
different columns there's data about uh
the date or when the when the request is
created
the status of request what kind of
request it was you know when it was
closed and and so many things and lots
of other piece information
this is like a fairly typical data set
but the goal is now can we start asking
questions in english on this data and
uncover interesting insights so the way
this is set up at least for this demo is
i put this in snowflake
and this is our web interface
uh
so the way this setup is you want to be
collaborative so each time somebody logs
in over here they see you know what are
people asking how many people are asking
different kinds of questions
uh what's the activity and then have a
very conversational approach for people
to start asking questions so there's
some elements of slack and microsoft
teams in this interface so we have a
notion of channels
where a channel can either be a
one-on-one conversation that you have
with the bot or a group chat where a
bunch of people can be chatting with
each other
as well as the bot to uncover
interesting insights
uh so so there's a sample questions
people have asked
so now i'm starting a new thread over
here so one of the key
principles that we take
that we decide to embark on is is that
all data analysis should be
almost present as transcripts so very
often what happens in terms of
reproducibility
analysis you might ask us some questions
a few days back a few weeks back got
some answer
and unless you manually stored that
answer somewhere that's lost
right so one of the purposes of making
this conversation is that you want to
save transcripts of all your questions
that you ask on data so that later on i
can go back and see what did you ask and
you know what is somebody else comment
on this piece of data
so we have this notion of name threads
where you can you can see different
threads and actually different uh so i i
have this policy now where i represent i
create a a demo on that data so a couple
of weeks by this was in hartford so now
it's in austin but you start asking
questions so my first question is show
me some uh data about sample incidents
so i just asked austin 310 incidents and
this watch comes back this is showing
the different of the city the created
date method received search description
in this case the bot describes how best
to present it it's this decided to show
it as a table here because there are
lots of columns and uh and in other
cases it might show it as a bar graph or
a line chart or a pie chart or something
else
so let's take the next question so now
this is more descriptive so i just asked
what are the service descriptions right
so i'm going to explore data a little
bit ask more descriptive questions and
now these are different service
descriptions available in this data set
so you're going to get a list of all the
kinds of of issues so issues like you
know compost
brush and bulk data animal collection
and a whole bunch of others
um next question is what are the ways
these uh these methods were received
method received whether it came by email
by phone two one one so there's a
variety of descriptive questions where
behind the scenes what happens is that
each of these questions gets translated
into sql query that goes to the
snowflake database gets back the answer
once also comes back we figured out best
to present how best to present it so ask
what are the zip codes and now these are
zip codes where you have these incidents
coming in place
so that's some basic you know some
questions that just helped us understand
a bit more about what data is coming
over here
i can also have explore the data in
different ways so we have a stat
interface you can ask exploration
questions i asked just now what is the
total number of incidents uh in this
case one point two two million incidents
uh keep the limit of data what are the
different attributes or different
metrics that have been defined
so
uh so let's ask
let's ask a slightly more complex
question over here right so
i'm i'm asking number of graffiti
incidents in 78701 last month right so
so this is slightly more complex
question where there are actually a
couple of different filters you know one
graffiti 78701 has to be interpreted now
correctly in this case a zip code it's a
time filter so
behind this so now the system is going
to figure out this out and one of the
key ideas here is that we want to
present
an understanding of the question back to
the user so when i asked number of
graffiti incidents in 7801 last month
it's come back with an answer the answer
was 13 but beyond that it said a few
other things that added context to the
answer and so one of the things it said
is that i interpreted the term graffiti
as a filter
where service describe description
contains graffiti that's one way of
interpreting a term graffiti which is
important from a semantic point of view
and i'll tell you why we uh why it's
interpreted this way in this case
it also decided that zip code the 17701
zip code and last month is last month so
in this case last month specifically
interpreted as february 20 22.
so one of the key ideas over here like
the previous talk where it's a human in
a machine interacting
just because you asked a question called
i can answer the machine is not just not
just saying uh the answer but also
giving information on how it interpreted
the question so it's clear exactly what
are the different
elements that went in what are the
different filters or groupings or
sorting that went in to create the
answer
all right so digging a bit more so
synthetic graffiti incidences is this
is interpreted that way and just
remember that because i'll show you how
the semantic layers is defined so this
is the actual sql query that got
generated behind the scenes if you
wanted to know exactly how what you know
uh if you want to if you didn't trust
the answer if you wanted to you know
create a sequel
and see
which table is hitting what the filter
clause is what's the wear condition and
and so on uh this is the sql query so
allows transparency into the system
uh
and uh
yeah let's see it
keep going on
so
uh so one of the key things here is a
semantic layer right so uh so when uh
let's see what's the next one
so let's see let's see why in this case
it decided to the
the semantics we just have to interpret
graffiti as you know all services that
contain the term graffiti team so in
this data set you know as it happens
there is some uncleanness so and this is
true for most data sets that there are
actually at different points in time in
the city of austin over the past 12
years this is something i found there
were
two different ways in which the term
for for describing graffiti incidents so
between 2014 and 18 or so it is called
graffiti abatement uh incidents and
after that started being called public
health graffiti abatement right and
that's something you see in data often
that you know you might the terms used
by change and so on so but when somebody
asks graffiti it could mean either of
these so one of these one and one of the
key things we do is to have a semantic
layer where
we can create a mapping or definition
that when somebody says graffiti it
could mean either of these so anything
that contains the term graffiti is a
it's a graffiti incident right so
so
so that helps us in
overcoming the challenge of possibly
unclean data where the terminology might
not be might not be well defined might
be changing over time and still allow
people to ask questions in a very
reliable manner to the system
so there's two kinds of
of
graffiti incidents
and yeah
so let's uh you know zoom in a bit so
let's ask a few more kinds of questions
so there's top five service descriptions
in order the number of days average day
is open so another slightly more complex
question where i'm ordering the
different incident types based on how
what's the average time they were they
were left open
and in this case the some of the biggest
ones were on basic needs appointment or
dumpsters or residential
uh rebates and so on
so there aren't any of these resonates
with the folks in austin over here
uh
but the other thing that we do is to
generate a natural language narrative as
well so there's beyond understanding the
the question there's also a narrative
that that describes
what more information came back and some
interesting uh
interesting insights in that in that
data
i can ask you know trend questions like
the number of incidents monthly
and then and the interesting thing i saw
over here is that uh there's actually a
nice seasonality where more instances
are reported between say march and june
and less incidents after that maybe
because of all the events in in austin
the period of time
uh but also says for instance that may
2021 had the most number of of of
complaints uh reported
so as soon as you find something
interesting we there's a model that we
that we borrow from pinterest where i
can pin interesting insights to a board
and see the uh and keep it for posterity
and also share it more easily so
essentially you can very quickly create
interesting dashboards on on the data
uh so now in this case we saw this let's
see we see this big spike this happened
to be i think in in march 2021 there's a
big spike in in incidents right uh
so one of the kinds of questions we
support is why questions so i could ask
a question like why is the number of
incidents
in march 2021 uh higher than february 21
and because that's where i want to
compare those two months
in this case actually builds up a model
behind the scenes on on what are the
factors that that drive in incidents
there are different values different
dimensions that ex that could explain
what changed between those two months
and this happens on the fly
so here's a slightly bigger energy uh
that talks about you know the biggest
changes or the biggest factors that
could explain this
so for instance over here you know it's
come back and said that the number
instance rose by 61 percent the top
reason is that there was a big increase
in number of incidents of type you know
missed yard trimmings
so that jumped by 798 percent and that
it
says is the biggest reason for
that contributed to why so many more
incidents in in march compared to
february and some other instances as
well certain zip codes like
7870478701 had lots more incidents uh
micro mobility incidents and others so
this is an example for why question and
then we can
dig into this bit more so this is where
the conversational aspect comes in
because it's very rare that the first
question you ask is going to get to the
inside that you are looking for
but so now let me dig deeper you know
what happened in missed yard trimmings
right so let me ask a question on number
of misty r trimmings monthly so now get
a line chart or trend line on on missed
yard charts and then we see this big
spike right in march 2021 there are so
many more incidents of missed yard
trimmings
so
so we think data analysis i trade all
right it's you have to keep asking more
questions you keep taking your data
today though with just plain dashboards
or reports that kind of thing is not
possible
another feature of a conversation system
is that it's it's conversational so
your subsequent questions could be
interpreted in the context of previous
questions so my first question in this
particular in that particular segment
was number of uh
missed yard trimmings monthly and then i
said buy zip code so depending on the
question one of the models that you
built under the scenes is predicting if
any given question is a new line of
analysis or the continuation of a
previous previous line of analysis so in
this case it's figure out a case it's a
continuation of a previous line so when
i said by zip code uh it's going to try
to
show you both by month and by zip code
what happened
so here and again it's given some an
energy narrative on which zip codes and
which months had had the biggest uh
number of uh missed yard trimmings
complaints
and here let's look at line chart it's
pretty busy the loss of zip codes that
this data set covers so maybe this is
too busy let me try to filter some more
let me just say in march 2021 again part
of the conversation of just asking
questions you need to interpret the
contents of previous
questions
so let's go back and in this case uh
let's look at a map so which zip codes
in march 2021 had the you know had how
many
missed yard trimming incidents and then
we see like two big spikes and you know
a couple of zip codes i think uh seven
eight uh seven three seven and seven
eight seven five i don't know if any of
you live in those zip codes okay
uh
so
yeah so this is you know quickly uh you
know figuring out some interesting
insights from from the data through
natural language uh queries
uh
this is so the last part of the show is
around uh uh analytics so one of the
kinds of analysis that we have in the
product is association rules and
many of you are very familiar with that
but the idea is to find out what are
interesting associations between
different variables in the data set so i
can just ask our top 20 associations
right
and then
this actually there's a there's a batch
process which catalyst which mines the
rules and then presents them but this
happens on on the fly right so and again
the part of the idea here is that we're
going to completely automate data
science almost so even training of
modeling of associated model training of
time series forecasting models and most
would say more typical classical machine
learning models we think can be
automated over time so
so here's let's come back with the top
association so for instance the top
association here is that
zip code 78702
that came in through mass entry
had a very high association with
graffiti abatement
then 7701 had lots of issues around
parking parking machine issues so
those associations are not discovered
automatically presented to the user and
data scientists could then take this and
improve the model if they want to but
this gives you a first cut
model on the fly configured fairly in
automated fashion and presented to the
users
and now the user can go and at least get
start exploring these maybe talk you
know explore more for instance on what
happened with parking machine issues in
78701 and which months had worse or
which kinds of users reported them and
so on
so that's a
quick overview of you know our vision of
conversational analytics we still have
ways to go to make it completely usable
but that's the that's the that's why you
want to take this to to make you know
eventually data sciences uh you know ai
powered
uh this is showing the energy behind it
so how it's explaining some of these uh
concepts uh so for instance saying that
there's a strong association between
seven eight seven zero two and and
graffiti i know anybody's 7702 in the
audience and we can validate the
graffiti issue that might be prevalent
there
uh and then giving start stats as well
so it's also talking about things like
confidence and lift and other metrics to
talk to say you know why is this an
important or interesting uh
aspect so one of the key things that
makes this work is a semantic layer uh
and you know there'll be lots of talks
again on semantic layers metric layers
around data right and and for us this
there's a very heavy dependence for us
on a semantic layer you know and we've
seen happy to see progress in things
like dbt and transform others on on but
i think it's still very you know barely
scratching the surface and i think
what's needed to have true semantics not
just defining metrics but almost
defining what's the meaning of certain
concepts right and how should certain
terms be actually interpreted so here's
the example that i showed before
so once we realized that for instance
graffiti had this interesting
characteristic that there were two
different terms for almost the same
thing at different points in time in the
data set we had to create a semantic
model saying that whenever somebody asks
anything about graffiti
you know look for these two concepts in
this case defined as if graffiti is
anything that can any service
description that contains the word
graffiti in it should be included in
when when they talk about graffiti so
i'm defining graffiti as service
descriptions that contains
in the string manner the the substring
graffiti
so that's what we often miss semantic
semantic layers so now other examples
are very often you see data sets where
you'll have a general column and
the gender column is m's and f's
right and implicitly we all know that m
means male f means female but there
could be some other weird cases i also
see in cases where the gender column has
zeros and ones and implicitly somebody
somewhere new zero mean meant male one
and female
but that those are semantics that that
we need to capture to allow people to
ask questions and data so
when somebody says how many female
customers are there
this semantic layer needs to know that
behind the scenes it needs to have where
you know gender is equal to zero for
instance so
there's a lot of semantic you know we
put a lot of effort into figuring out
what's the right semantic layer that is
needed to capture those implicit
semantics and data that
that
that can really help improve the
accuracy of the nlp
so
so this is we have a notion of a
thesaurus uh we have a notion of our own
richer ontology of data types so beyond
the basic data types that you mentioned
databases that we also define much more
regentology things like location things
like currency latitude longitude you
know a whole bunch of other things
that often helped also in in limited
recognition in the nlp side
you can also define metrics that way so
metrics are
matrix i think good work is happening
with metrics but you can also define
metrics in this in this system
uh you can define more new variables for
instance like days open is a new metric
or a new variable where
we subtract find the difference between
the days closed and the
day open
uh here's an example of how we configure
association rules where
if if a data scientist data analyst
wants to fine-tune or tailor how some of
those models are being trained
it's you can configure and say okay i'm
looking for associations between zip
code and method received to service
description
and that's the that's the hint you get
the system to help it constrain the
space that they're searching for when
it's time to come up with interesting
insights and patterns and data so trying
to make even uh
analytics be ui driven the data science
ui driven data science almost right
[Music]
so that's the semantic layer and i'll
i'll talk a bit more about uh what goes
on in the semantic layer but that's the
you know a quick demo of our vision of
conversational uh exploration of data
so let's uh
take that
let me see how much time okay i'll
quickly go through some of the remaining
slides so um this is like five minutes
more
oh
yeah oh yeah got it yep thanks uh
uh it's a very high level you know we
have a fairly sophisticated lp pipeline
uh because it's a you know
it turned a fairly challenging task to
understand often grammatically incorrect
and vaguely expressed natural language
queries into converted sequel at the
very end right so it's a very simple
there's lots of other pieces that go
into it like spelling correction and uh
tokenization normalization and so on but
some of the key things that that will
spend a lot of time to figure out how to
make good work are things like entity
recognition recognizing that not like
segmenting firstly the the whole uh the
the the tokens in this that number of
trips is one concept
winter 2017 is another concept
agent genders or the concepts that's the
segmentation and then figuring out how
to interpret them you know what
when you have those kinds of concepts
coming in what could be a kind of query
so in this case maybe it's an
aggregation query with some filters and
uh
and then also deciding how to interpret
certain things
winter 2017 is a general concept
but now it has to be converted to a date
range because in sql it has to be date
range
so coming up with all you know the right
interpretations you know going step by
step from you know complete sentences to
talk to entities to you know
matching them to a database and then
find generating a sql query where the
sequels also has to depend on the
specific database
and then going to the final getting the
result and presenting it so in a sense
the way you can almost think of this as
like english to french or english to
german translation
except that there are probably a million
different french's because each database
has his own french or or in german so we
take an almost a language translation
approach with a lot of customizability
that because every database is unique
right so
and every database has its own semantics
so for instance you know if if i asked a
question on austin in the ross 311
austin meets austin but if i ask the
same question i am db database most
likely you know is going to talk about
austin powers so the term austin is
totally dependent on the data behind the
scenes right so that's something which
we had to you know spend our time and
figuring out how to how to make it work
so
a key challenge that that we face is
bridging the gap between users and data
and that's where semantic model comes in
so as we've you know
brought the system out and got some
customers in and lots of other pilots so
some of the key challenges we've seen
are
when presented to system like this users
often don't know what to ask they don't
know how to ask them you know there's
often ambiguity and how they frame their
questions
now most users are not familiar with you
know there's filters and group by they
ask just ask questions they would just
say customers
implicitly they think they mean number
of customers but that's very implicit
right so
so that whole ambiguity is an important
with a big challenge for us
and finally users may not use terms in
the data set that that already the out
of data set issue is is pretty
challenging especially
so on the data status but there are lots
of different issues right so data could
involve different ways the different
kinds of schemas different implicit
assumptions and you know you know
whether it's normalized normalized uh
what is the meaning of some sometimes
you have tables that act like join
tables for you know and and cross them
relationships uh sometimes you have
so there's lots of different patterns of
modeling data databases some good and
some bad
and still we had to you know we made the
assumption that you know you can't
change the data the data is as it is
because in many cases that's what it is
and then but you can add a layer on top
of it that will try to make it easier
for for users to query
so often lots of hidden semantics uh
data might be incomplete and unclean
like the like the case assured and the
awesome data and finally data might be
spread across silos
so
so let me take an example of a deeper
example a semantic model so this is uh
the other data set this is on city bike
bike share data uh so
so let's say that the physical data
model had had you know had these kinds
of attributes as a trips table that had
start time stop time trip duration and
so on
and the user is asking a question like
what's the number of rides by age group
right so there's a there's lots of terms
here that's not presented in the actual
data model there's nothing called the
age group in the data model there's
nothing called uh
rights is not this but something called
trips so there's some mapping that needs
to happen and that's that's the
semantics that needs to to emerge on the
data for users to ask questions
so
as an example some of the semantics that
you might want to capture is that uh
uh for instance age range is something
that could be extracted or derived from
birth yet there might be a formula to
derive age range from birth here
uh another semantic that that we support
is is defining not just metrics but
something as we call segments because
you could ask questions like
how you know what's the average number
of trips taken by old customers
what's an old customer so you're going
to define the semantics what is the
meaning of old in this context and maybe
it's based on again the birth year
so so all those are semantics that that
slowly we keep and adding more and more
semantic information to make it easier
for
for the users to ask more questions more
naturally uh but yeah but then now
become this process now where the
semantics are are
you can define them through the ui but
they can be version they can be you know
even very often checked in into a source
control system
and then you can keep collaboratively
expanding the semantics as as time goes
on
uh so yeah so the way typically this is
set up is that cuba system between users
and databases
when we first set up the system it
crawls the data it comes up with an
initial semantic model based on our
prior knowledge or prior experiences of
what data looks like typically
but then the data modeler mistake can
come in and add more information using
that ui i briefly showed and then those
semantics now get used so that whenever
a user asks a question the first thing
it does is is figure out which data
source database might have the question
might be able to answer the question
convert it to a sql query get back the
answer and then present the answer back
to the users like i showed you
so a stop here there's time for some
questions uh but you know this is
already our vision of future of work
efficient data and how people might
explore data using conversations
[Applause]